هذه المره حضر فولودي ميرزيلينسكي شخصيا
ليخاطب الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده من
هذا المنبر الذي غاب عنه العام الماضي
بسبب احتدام الحرب في بلاده اعتبر ان
روسيا تستخدم طرقا جديده في الحرب
منذ بدايه الحرب اغلقت روسيا الموانئ
الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود وبحر ازور لا
تزال موانئنا حتى اليوم على نهر الدانوب
هدفا للصواريخ والمسيرات ومن الواضح ان
روسيا تحاول استغلال نقص المواد الغذائيه
في السوق العالميه للحصول على اعتراف من
اشخاص معينين او حتى من بعض المناطق التي
استولت عليها
المنافسه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
كانت ايضا حاضره بقوه في خطاب جو بايدن
الرئيس الامريكي سعى الى توضيح موقف بلاده
من المساله
عندما يتعلق الامر بالصين اريد ان اكون
واضحا وملتزما الى اداره المنافسه بين
بلدينا بشكل مسؤول حتى لا تتحول المساله
الى نزاعه
في كلمته رسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش صوره قاتمه لعالم تسوده
التوترات الجيوسيه
درنا هي مثال حي وحزين مما يجري في عالمنا
علم مليء باللمساواه والظلم ويستحيل فيه
رفع هذه التحديات
اما الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان فقال
ان بلاده تدعم خطوات اذربيجان للحفاظ على
وحده وسلامه اراضيها وذلك بعد انشنت باكو
عمليه عسكريه في اقليم ناكورني كارباخ